in the diagram below quadrilateral efgh
so that's this one here was obtained by
performing a sequence of transformations
on quadrilateral a b c d
and then they tell us the information
that's already written here measure of
angle a is 69 degrees measure of angle b
is 102 degrees measure of angle g is 145
degrees and measure of angle h is 44
degrees
which of the following additional facts
is sufficient to conclude that the only
transformations used were translations
rotations reflections and dilations and
not any other kind of transformations
so this is another way of saying if we
if we only use translations rotations
reflections and dilations then that
means that these two figures are similar
so if this is the case and we're dealing
with similar
we're dealing with similar
quadrilaterals so another way of saying
this is which of these facts so either
this first fact or the second fact or
both of them or neither of them which of
these facts are sufficient in order to
determine that these two quadrilaterals
are similar which is another way of
saying that you could go from one to
another only through translations
rotations reflections and dilations
so let's look at this first
this first set of facts right over here
so they give us the measure of angle c
is 145 degrees so they tell us that that
right over there is
145 degrees and actually i could just
write a
145 degrees right over there and they
tell us that the measure of angle e is
69 degrees so they tell us that this is
69 degrees
so with that piece of information right
over here
we know in each of these quadrilaterals
we know three of the angles and we need
to figure out and because we know three
we can figure out the fourth we can
figure it out because the sum of the
angles in a quadrilateral are going to
add up to 360 degrees so if we wanted to
figure out the measure of angle x the
measure of angle f right over here let's
say that is x we could say that x
plus 69 degrees plus 145 degrees plus 44
degrees
is equal to
360 degrees
so let's get the calculator out right
over here our x would essentially be 360
minus these things so 360
minus
minus 44
is 102 degrees so this angle right over
here is 102 degrees
now notice
these two already have three angles in
common they have a 69 degree let me
color code it so
this angle right over here has a measure
of 69 degrees so does this one then you
move one over this angle right over here
is 102 degrees whoops i wanted to do
that in blue 102 degrees so is this one
then you move to the next angle
is 145 degrees i've already used that
green the next angle 145 degrees well
that would correspond to this 145
degrees and if you know three of the
angles you know that this last one right
over here this fourth one
was going to have to be 44 degrees you
could take 360 and from it subtract 145
102 and 69 and you will get 44 degrees
you will get 44 degrees 44 degrees so
you have two quadrilaterals where all of
these angles are congruent to each other
so if you have if you have these two
shapes and all and you have all the
corresponding angles are congruent to
each other
then you know that they are similar and
if you know that they are similar you
know that you can go from one to another
purely purely through some combination
of translations which is really just
shifting it in two dimensions rotating
it around some points reflecting it
which you can kind of use flipping it
over around some line and dilations
which is scaling it up or down so the
first one is definitely so this one is
definitely good let's see if the second
one could also independently help us
determine that these two things are
similar
so what i'm going to do
i'm going to do is clear this out so i
have some space to work with
so let me clear it out
let me clear this out right over here
and now let's think about what the
second
statement is telling us
the second statement tells us the
measure of angle d is 44 degrees so
they're saying that is 44 degrees and
that the measure of angle f is 102
degrees
is 102 degrees
so once again it it's given us one more
angle in each of them and from that we
can figure out the last angle and so if
you know all of the angles inside of
in two quadrilaterals you can determine
if they are similar they're going to be
similar only if only if all of the
corresponding or if you have four
corresponding angles that are congruent
to each other
so this is this is this fact is to well
let me just show it to you just since i
don't say that it's enough let's
calculate this last angle right over
here we can get our calculator back out
it's going to be
360.
minus 102
minus 145
minus 44 minus 44
which is equal to 69 degrees
so this right over here is 69 degrees so
notice 102 degrees
then 69 degrees
then 44 degrees 6 102 degrees 69 degrees
44 degrees and so this last one has to
be
145 degrees just like this one if three
of the angles are the same that fourth
one has to be the same
so
this angle corresponds to this angle
this angle corresponds to that angle
and then finally this angle corresponds
to
this angle you have two quadrilaterals
the interior four angles are all
congruent they correspond to each other
so they must be similar and so you can
get from one to another through
translations rotations reflections and
dilations so this one
is also good so actually either of these
are sufficient in order to conclude that
the only transformations used were these
so i would click
both answers are correct